eddie van halen i know you got to
interview him once for four hours
that's the best part i think of fame in
a way that you get access to your heroes
you know awesome why did you interview
him for four hours what was the
circumstance
i used to work with this guitar magazine
and uh i had this idea
interviewing eddie because i i thought
you know my generation
the alternative people don't really know
van halen so i was like let's introduce
eddie to this
generation of kids they should know that
this is really one of our heroes right
and the guitar magazine was very like oh
you know they were afraid i was going to
say something stupid i don't know blow
their relationship with him so
i went in it was only supposed to be an
hour he was great i was with him for
like four and a half hours
played guitar we talked [ __ ] about
everything he showed me all the
unreleased van halen music i mean it was
like the grand tour of all time
i mean you talk about like a 10 out of
10 experience in my life and he was
great he was so awesome
i got to know him a little bit
afterwards he was always super gracious
last time i saw him came to one of our
shows i mean it doesn't get any better
than that
and and literally the best of the best
of the best there's no like oh you know
there's no asterix next to a name and he
was literally the best of the best
do you buy into the fact that he was a
great guitar player because he
really didn't listen to rock and roll
music he was
not influenced by a lot of musicians in
a way
i i go the other way i think he was so
gifted that his
his version of reality was something we
were willing to accept
like like i have my version of reality
but not everybody likes it
somehow his virgin reality was like hey
i'll take that and i'll take more of
that
i think it just came out of his hands
that way you listen to early van halen
bootlegs even before their first album
it's already there the full package is
already there he's already playing like
a
madman and i asked him during that
interview i said
at what point did you realize like you
were that guy and he just like shrugged
his shoulders said i just used to sit on
the edge of my bed and just practice and
practice
like in his mind it was like almost
mystifying
wasn't a conscious thing with him he was
just that good and that's why you'd
watch him play he would be like laughing
it was like
he was doing the most insane stuff just
kind of laughing and smoking a cigarette
and telling jokes that
he's like how is this possible but it
was he was the real thing
when you interviewed him were you out of
studio were you at his house yeah i went
to his house
where he had a studio on the property
wow that sounds like heaven for
i mean that just sounds fantastic and
when you're playing with him
are you playing van halen songs and are
you showing him that you can play all of
those riffs on the guitar
no most of the time he had a guitar in
his hands and he was playing you know
like like it was almost like he would
punctuate his sentences by playing i
don't
know i mean he was like talking and
playing and playing and talking
and then um at some point in the
interview he said he hands takes the
guitar off and he hands it to me he says
let me see you play
he's like oh no yeah [ __ ] me right
what did you play he just wanted me to
just play he didn't want me to play
anything he just wanted me to like kind
of see how i played maybe
or how to write more apt and so i kind
of did some stuff that i do
and he kind of laughed and said kind of
like chuckled and said oh you can
actually play
so when he saw that i could play the
guitar then he totally changed it was
like i was entered into the other club
and then he started telling me all this
other stuff that was like guitar stuff
right and then he got really excited he
was showing me equipment
and guitars and come over here and look
at this and
it was like it was a dream come true and
he was the greatest he was just so
wonderful he was such a nice person too
as you know
he just he was generally just that guy